built on a lie and then devastated by a
storm today the historic scotty's castle
in death valley remains off limits it's
been that way for more than six years
since a flash flood forced the site to
close john langler checks on its
restoration
things are still the same you still
can't get to scotty's castle unless abby
wines lets you she works for death
valley national park it is correct to
say it was built on a line scotty's
castle sits above death valley in the
early 1920s con man walter scott
convinced chicago businessman albert
johnson to invest in a gold mine here
but it was a con
johnson though wasn't upset about being
swindled instead the pair built this
majestic vacation home in the middle of
nowhere it's a really beautiful special
place with a fun history really unique
western history then in 2015 mother
nature nearly swept it all away we lost
our water system our road our sewer
system electrical power a year's worth
of rain fell in one burst above the
castle it was still a mess when we
visited five years ago after the flood
while the road is now fixed there's
still a lot of work to do the latest
setback the planned visitor center
burned down last april we really
originally thought it would take three
or four years and now we're at six years
and looking at another year and a half
probably until the castle's open at the
end it could cost up to 60 million
dollars to get scotty's castle in a
state where you can go see it all the
time as well
so why do it that's normally a question
that gets asked by people who have never
been here before david blacker runs the
death valley natural history association
once you come here and once you see
this amazing place in this incredible
location in
what is an absolutely amazing desert
you stop asking that question one day a
week blacker leads extremely limited
castle tours
but don't bother asking they're booked
for 2022. still the park service hopes
to open some more spots in the fall and
they're planning to fully reopen now in
april 2023
it's just a unique priceless place it'll
take a little more time to restore a
place time forgot
in death valley john langley live local
now
by the way death valley national park
just let us know today that over a
million people visited the park last
year in 2021. now if you're interested
in seeing the castle you can get some
updates on when those tour slides might
be opening online we'll have that
information for you at eightnewsnow.com